so I wanted to prove that all marketing
was the same thing no matter what you're
selling it was always the same thing
right and good marketing talked about
the buyer and bad marketing talked about
the seller makes sense I versus you
right so to illustrate my point I wanted
to prove that what the homeless do and
what Microsoft does is the same thing so
if you think about what the homeless do
there is advertising they sit there with
a little sign that says I'm homeless I'm
hungry I got six kids I'm a veteran like
whatever whatever whatever trying to
appeal to everybody that's called a
little billboard right Microsoft has a
billboard that says more memory bigger
screen all the rest of it right more RAM
or ROM right and what the homeless are
selling is goodwill so if you walk past
a homeless person you put money in their
cup you feel good if you give them
nothing you either feel nothing or feel
bad you paid for that feeling there's an
exchange of consideration I sold you
goodwill you paid for it you got it
right they're selling goodwill that's
what they're doing they're selling the
feeling of goodwill so I found a
homeless person who was willing to help
me and you heard her sign was pretty
typical and I found out that she makes
between twenty and thirty dollars a day
selling goodwill and she works in 8 to
10-hour day right $30 is considered a
good day right selling goodwill like I
said her sign was pretty typical so I
asked if I could change her sign we did
and the sign that I gave her she made
$40 in two hours the sign that I gave
her said if you only give once a month
please think of me next time it wasn't
about the seller it was about the giver
what are the reasons people say they
don't give how do I know that they're
genuine I can't give to everyone so I
simply answer the questions if you only
give once a month please think of me
next time I know you can't give to
everybody I'm legit that's all right
now here's the point I was gonna make
she could have made $150 that day but
after she made her $40 in two hours she
left because one of the reasons she's
homeless or we could
we couldn't surmise that one of the
reason she's homeless is she's decided
that she needs 20 or 30 dollars to live
per day so once she had it she moved on
that's a narrative it's a narrative
right so she'll stay there because she
didn't sit longer
that's a narrative so there's a
wonderful little trick you can use with
your narrative right just add the word
yet at the end okay I'll never get I'm
not famous yet not that talented yet I'm
so bad I'm not good at auditions like I
need to get better any like I suck at
auditions for now right you can just add
a couple of words of hope or opportunity
or the potential for future or some sort
of infinite component that will
profoundly change your narrative
[Music]